prenda tutti ragazzi è ben vero che mi
sono video sono fa vj oggi siamo il
nuovo blog non l'avreste mai detto sto
indossando questo cappello perché ogni
allora con il bios i cappelli e perché
ciò di capelli di merda perché ogni
tanto mi sveglio la mattina e dico non
c'ho voglia di usare il pettine allora
prima di iniziare vi non mi metto il
cappello così sono a posto sono cioè
tipologiche ho messo questo mi sono
accorto che c'è un occhio un po più
storto sembra triste questa cosa molto
triste
sì un ragazzi prima di cominciare come
se in teoria di partire per la parte
della settimana che questa settimana è
stata vinta da wal mart che navi infine
un'altra 65 ma c'è un uomo nudo che sta
passando
perché c'è un uomo nudo che passò nel
ministri tanto lo metto questo lo metto
lo metto lo mettiamo
sto dicendo loro ci ha vinto quei l'art
la fanta settimana qualche mese fa ma
dio mio santo di osmi complimenti sei
stata fantastica nonché ragazzi passando
le news volevo ringraziarvi di cuore ma
veramente tantissimo perché da quando
non so più parlare italiano selezioniamo
il tedesco della prossima volta come
lingua standard dopo dicendo che dalla
scorsa settimana mi sono arrivato in
occasioni messaggi di foto di tantissimi
di voi che hanno preso l'album ragazzi
non so come ringrazio veramente non me
la sarei mai veramente aspettato che
così tante persone veramente io in
realtà non quando mi hanno proposto di
fare l'album io ho detto vabbè come va
va tanto è una cosa bella da fare punto
ma non mi veramente non mi sarei mai
aspettato così tanto buon riscontro
quindi veramente vi ringrazio di cuore
ragazzi molti mi scrivono continuamente
anche il fatto che magari non lo trovano
perché esaurito perché sono sono presi
in troppi ed era esaurito perché è
successo dio mio santo per chi non
riuscisse a trovarlo c'è una mail in
descrizione da dove potete richiedere di
farvi inviare l'album 6 mandate il
vostro indirizzo su questa mail quindi
ve la lascio quindi è scritto né per chi
fosse interessato io vi ringrazio
veramente tantissimo ragazzi ha detto
questo volevo farvi vedere come la
panini è enorme come come società ha
fatto una conferenza stampa sul mio
album dove ho dovuto partecipare anch'io
so che non ho mai fatto una cosa del
genere vita mia la conferenza stata una
roba veramente seria in gente in giacca
e cravatta di solito è poi ci sono
andato io e l'ho presa molto molto sullo
scatto mi piace fare il tamarro in
macchina tanto non guido io cook reja ci
sto tipo correndo alla conferenza niente
spero di non fare figure di merda datami
aiutarmi aiuta anche ax che lui e se lui
venisse domineremo il mondo iniziano
molto presto ecco questo è il mio
portinaio che mi apre la porta
l'auser perché mi tira dal braccio
va bene praticamente stiamo per entrare
in questa su questo posto dove c'è la
conferenza stampa io continua regista
tranquillamente a mo di sel fi mentre
quelli tipo giornalisti
vuoi fare silenzio ma che continuano a
registrare sbatter casa facendo foto
scappiamo devo aspettare un attimino di
nuovo a vari esempi bruttissimo farei la
gente mi guarda a quanto sono simply
hanno anche regalato questa cosa fa
minati può essere una sorta di poster
tipo figurine dei calciatori sono in
formato gigante un'europa [ __ ] niente me
la prenderò in bagno quando call call me
lo vedo evento queste ragazzine che
possiamo passare a farvi risponde
stavolta ho selezionato delle domande
che manco i critici della letteratura
italiana avrebbero mai potuto fare delle
domande del genere di tre figli pronti
poi risponde fuori canta una canzone a
tuo piacimento mentre bevi alcune sale
cose mi vengono in mente al cesso ciò
che chiedo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ho 13 anni e anni e guido meglio di te
guarda con tredici anni direi che puoi
fare qualsiasi cosa credo non puoi
sederti su troppe cose appuntite però
ciao siamo due cugini andate aver
guardare i nostri video tutti questo
nuovo video social web e ios amina
pijamose scusa bevarage al mar
siamo tutti i giochi che sommandosi a
scuola che ha fatto quello che volevamo
[Musica]
per fare questa cosa mi dovrò servire di
un amico
sei pronto e benvenuti in questo nuovo
video rinvenuti in questo sono una
scimmia tutti ai porca [ __ ] e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video io sono
edward cullen e mi puzzano le celle
scusate per il pigiama aver saltato
scuola e quindi conclude ragazzi per i
miei mi stavo limiti khalifa l'ho
scartato dei panther e poi mi scassate
marone destro faccio lo scat aggio del
pacchetto come astenete di scarto
insieme a cazzo però di non trovare mie
foto nudo alla famiglia della serie tipo
ma chi è che ha scoraggiato io geniale
cup questa la donna questa e beli queste
veramente belli e la mia per l'ho
trovata anche rara katz molto peggio
molto molto peggio basta perché sembra
che io stia leggendo di bourne cos'è sta
roba ragazzi lascio perdere questa cosa
che scende nel trash molto facilmente
perché un chiude ragazzine di passare
alla famiglia mandela freddo wanda di
oggi è che secondo voi questo cappello e
triste avrà visto cose brutte in bagno
molto peggio di questa potevano sapere
con un commento qui sotto e io cercherò
di capirlo come sei ragazzi se vi è
piaciuto perché mi piace ma capace di
facebook e come vestizione queste cose
ci si scaglia non ci vediamo al prossimo
video [ __ ] a [ __ ] vaffanc
urna perché io faccio dall'altro veloce
manco dire di reazione fisica grazie
grazie
da ragazzi